I have to imagine it was and continues
to be so gratifying to have sort of
received the
satisfaction of approval from the
Presley family from the late Lisa Marie
and Priscilla who were there for you at
the Golden Globes and it sounds like
kind of we're there for you every step
of the way and saying you got it right
and if anybody's going to say that I
guess you want to hear it from them yeah
but I I
yeah
um
I remember the moment they were first
going to watch the film
I had never been more nervous for
anybody to see anything than I'd ever
done
because they they hadn't seen anything
and they didn't even read the script at
that point with um
and uh
and so and they were very nervous and um
I really thought it could go either way
and and then when baz read me
Priscilla's email
uh I just burst into tears because it
was um
I felt so much responsibility to them
and and and and and for their family and
and um and for Elvis's Legacy and
it was just
yeah it was such a such a beautiful
moment and then and then when I finally
got to meet Lisa Marie because we didn't
meet until
um we screened the film at Graceland
and when I
blocked eyes on her it's a really
surreal thing when
I I I've been playing her dad for such a
long time and um
and and been doing my best to to
make it as true for me as possible
the the relationship you know of
of
um
feeling the love
for her through her father
um
and then because of the film resonated
with her in that way suddenly
now is this moment where we're standing
in front of each other and we're looking
into each other's eyes and I felt so
much love for her through him and that
whole process
um
that I've never felt closer to somebody
quicker than I felt with her and um and
then she she was just the most
incredible woman I've ever met and just
so
um
so incredibly honest and loving
and
he had to just to just finally be able
to give her a hug and
um
and then to spend all those moments with
her
um so it's really it's really sad right
now you know yeah I mean it's such an
emotional time anyway around everything
that's happening for you professionally
that added layer of her passing must
give us an entire new depth yeah a
profound depth of feeling around what's
happening right now with the movie yeah
yeah
um and it's it's
yeah it's so I mean I've said it in in
these exact words but it's just very
Bittersweet right now
because it's
the
I just wish that she was here to
celebrate with us
um but I'm I and I'm just so
I'm so grateful that everybody has
received the story in the way that they
they have and
um to get recognition for
for their family you know and for her
dad who
I I know it weighed on her a lot how
misunderstood he was and
um
and so
to be a part of that I just feel so
endlessly privileged you know
[Music]